Hello, your watching
the UDusky Offline first course,
I'm Jake Archibald
broadcasting from London.
But we now go live to our US
correspondent Mike Wales.
Hi, Mike.
How's the weather over there?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Mike, Mike, you're breaking up.
You some like two dialects
having a rap battle.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Yep, yep, go ahead.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay, I think he's gone.
We had this whole news reader thing
planned, it was going to be fun.
With home broadband and
smart phones, the human race is
increasingly reliant on the internet.
But the internet isn't always with us.
I'm sure you're familiar with this.
[MUSIC]
>> That kind of thing.
The sinking feeling of being
abandoned by connectivity.
You're stuck outside while
the internet parties without you.
You can only imagine what
you're missing out on.
It could be anything,
literally anything.
A new video of a cat, a politician
saying something stupid, world peace
could be solved in 140 characters,
but you don't get to hear about it.
All you get is.
[MUSIC].
Total failure in the face of
connectivity issues is a worst case
scenario.
And it's all too common on the web,
but no longer.
In this course we're going to
cover how you can build sites and
apps that work great what
ever connection the user has.
We're going to use service worker
to intercept network traffic,
explore the latest service
work at dev tools.
We're going to tame IDB, the in browser
database, and explore user experience
strategies to deal with varying
network conditions and updates.
Overall we want to make
[NOISE] a thing of the past.